Так мало виглядати ідеальне літо
Але 21 липнядоведеться йти на...
парламентські вибори
Пробитися до Ради цього разу хочуть зо два десятка партій
Утім, далеко не всі вони подолають
прохідний 5-відсотковий бар’єр
і займуть депутатські крісла у сесійній залі
Соціологи пророкують:
найбільше шансів - у партій "Слуга народу",
"Опозиційна платформа-За життя",
"Європейська солідарність" та "Батьківщина"
До них можуть долучитися "Голос" та "Сила і честь".
Склад парламенту має суттєво оновитися
Дві партії -"Слуга народу" та "Голос" -
не брали до своїх списків чинних нардепів.
Щоправда, серед мажоритарників чимало старих облич.
Зокрема Ігор Кононенко, Віктор Балога,
Олесь Довгий,  Вадим Новинський, Сергій Ківалов тощо
Загалом за місця в Раді боротимуться майже
шість тисяч кандидатів - за округами і за партійними списками.
Серед них низка селебрітіс.
Співаки Святослав Вакарчук...
і Михайло Поплавський
За останнього агітує Олег Вінник
Щонайменше двох ветеранів у новому парламенті не вистачатиме
Перший пройшов крізь усі скликання -
з Дня Незалежності України
Це - колишній "регіонал" Юхим Звягільський,
який цього разу не балотується
Другий - Олег Ляшко - і землю на трибуні їв,
і корів під Радуприводив...
Але згідно з рейтингами, схоже, мандат таки не отримає
У бюлетенях чимало кандидатів від організацій
зі словами "слуга народу" у назві
Це і ТОВ, і підприємства, і громадські організації, і навіть благодійні фонди
Також до Ради балотуються дев’ять кандидатів із прізвищем Зеленський
Жоднихродинних зв’язків із чинним президентом вони не мають
Однак справжні родини у списках партій таки є
Наприклад, подружжя Шкрум-Наталуха балотується порізно
- за списками "Батьківщини" та "Слуги народу"
Серед кандидатів - лише кожна п’ята - жінка
Найбільше їх у першій десятці "Голосу" - кожна друга
Тоді як у топ-10 "Свободи" та "Опозиційного блоку"
жінок немає взагалі
Друк бюлетенів обійдеться бюджету у понад 280 млн грн
А загалом вибори коштуватимуть до 2 млрд грн
Результати голосування ЦВК має оголосити до 5 серпня
А перший дзвоник для депутатів нової Ради
має пролунати до 9 вересня.